J'ai appris que les dieux de l'Olympe sont
réels et parfois ils ont des enfants
avec des humains appelés métis. Nous
ressemblons à peu près à tous ceux que vous rencontrez,
mais avec quelques différences notables, nous
vivons dans le seul endroit sûr pour
notre espèce.  qui ferait cela
Kronos, le père Titan d'origine des
Olympiens destroyer de l'Olympe
Luke s'avère que vous n'êtes pas le seul
sang-mêlé qui est difficile à tuer
Je ressusciterai Kronos et les
Olympiens connaîtront la mort et chaque
demi-dieu sera tué en quelques jours si
pas plus tôt que notre sort appelle les meilleurs
d'entre nous les plus forts les plus courageux nous devons
les arrêter
J'ai besoin de votre aide
laissez-moi faire mes valises et assurez-vous que mon
assurance maladie est payée la seule
chose qui a le pouvoir de sauver notre
maison est le  Toison d'or c'est dans la
mer des monstres oh mon dieu
mais les humains ont appelé le
triangle des Bermudes s'il vous plaît
je veux aider ici brumiser ça rend le
mystique normal Wow alors une quête
dans des eaux inexplorées et mortelles avec
rien  ing moins en jeu que notre propre
survie
chacun était le plafond de cela vous avez libéré
les vents pour les quatre coins du
monde
qu'est-ce
que c'est où nous devons aller dites-moi que ce
ne sont pas des requins ce ne sont pas des requins
ça doit être le  pire façon de mourir
et tu dois sortir d'ici
Percy si Kronos revient et c'est tout
nous trouverons la toison que
je prendrai que je ne pense pas
[Musique]